one of the great things about the  department is a lot of us that work in  the department are fans there's a cover  by Marc bright that got me into  collecting comic books in Iron Man 3 I  had the honour of actually designing the  MCU version of the silver Centurion suit  and just the fanboy India was just like  going crazy like I couldn't believe it  it was surreal  what I'm very proud of is that those  suits look great from a distance but if  you get up close to them we have some  weapon systems offline oh you got it  you're gonna have to take this into the  shop there's a level of resolve to them  like they should exist in the world  something bad the fans are familiar with  but at the same time works well on film  awesome designers and the costume  departments can sort of feed off that  and not only match what we've created  but try to elevate it past it gave her  wings  you  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]